ever thought that the prehistoric land
of Oris and the Nepalese region of ki
raat looks slightly similar well you're
not wrong
as noticed by game pressure it appears
that much of Far Cry primal geography
has been pulled straight from far card 4
I'm Lucy and welcome to this copycat
game spot news updates so according to
findings reported by game pressure the
map in Far Cry primal replicates the
topography of the map in Far Cry 4 a
source close to Ubisoft allegedly
confirmed to Kotaku the Far Cry primal
developers used far cry 4 height maps as
a basis for their game
this makes sensing as the games did come
out so close to each other but what
would have been nice is if it was meant
to be set in the same region but primal
is set somewhere in Europe and we know
that Far Cry 4 is set in a fictional
region somewhere near the Himalayas so
did you think that aura felt familiar
are you agree that it's the same map or
do you not mind let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
twitter i'm Malusi james games for the
latest on far cry keep the game spot